good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight time for a confession
right off the bat there were times we
will admit it back in the dark ages of
cable news when we'd milk a single news
event for weeks in some cases and we're
talking to you O.J Simpson for months
and months and months there's wasn't
that much going on so you couldn't
afford to waste a good story that is not
the problem we are having these days the
problem now is the opposite of course
there's too much going on and some of
it's terrifying in just the last week
China signed a 50 billion dollar trade
deal with Saudi Arabia old Ally
signaling an end to America's
long-standing Global petrol Empire
that's not a small thing Vladimir Putin
meanwhile who runs Russia once again
threatened to launch a nuclear war on
the west then Wall Street began laying
off large numbers of people which is not
something you could ignore in an
industry whose business it is to predict
the future of the economy and at the
same time that was happening the wealth
of the average American household
dropped to one of the lowest levels ever
recorded the CDC responded by trying to
resurrect face masks because that'll
help
Sam bankman freed got arrested and then
the Mexican drug cartels which run the
largest human trafficking operation
since the transatlantic slave trade
ended now officially have control of our
Southern border
so it's been a busy week in fact more
has happened in this past week than it
happened during two full terms under
Bill Clinton
a lot so if you're running our country
right now you'd be staying up all night
every night trying to figure out how to
respond
but that's not what the buy
Administration is doing not at all this
afternoon as the old Global Order
collapses to be replaced by God knows
what the Biden people decided to hold a
drag event at the White House just in
case you were wondering if those
comparisons to vimar were overstated no
they're not overstated
the occasion for this celebration was
the official signing of the respect for
Marriage Act which the White House tells
us will codify gay marriage into law but
wait a moment you wonder wasn't gay
marriage legalized by the Supreme Court
way back under Barack Obama well yeah
but they've legalized it again it's
double legal
and you know what that means that means
it's time to hear from Lady Gaga
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
that I'm
[Music]
dance party at the White House hooray
what's been legal for years is still
legal break out the white claw
Cindy Lauper was there of course to
celebrate Cindy Lauper is going to be 70
years old this spring meaning she's
lived in this country a long time but
until today until this afternoon at the
White House under the beneficent gaze of
Joe Biden the great Cyndi Lauper
informed us that Americans were not
allowed to love each other until today
love was banned but Joe Biden changed
that and now we're free to love watch
this and see if you don't choke up just
a little
our families are validated and because
now we're allowed to love who we love
which sounds odd to say
but Americans can now love who we love
and
bless Joe Biden and all the people that
worked on this for allowing people not
to worry and their children not to worry
about their future
wait didn't that happen 10 years ago
well we checked that tape is from today
party was the White House today and that
means that somewhere our nuclear
disposal friend
Sam Brinton formerly of the energy
department is sitting atop a pile of
stolen women's clothes cursing the fact
that airports have security cameras in
the baggage claim damn those cameras if
only Britain hadn't been caught this
would have been like Christmas for him
he could have spent the morning in Cyndi
Lauper's dressing room trying to Perlo
in a new halter top talk about a missed
opportunity thankfully Marty Cummings
was there to make up for it Cummings is
a drag star who like Sam Britton has a
long history of unfiltered social media
posts F the police Cummings tweeted in
2020 yes we want to defund the police
yes we want to abolish ice no we won't
settle for anything less we'll continue
to fight for this to happen end quote
that sounds like antifa well yeah
and to prove it this year Cummings
promoted something called a cab coffee
using the All But copyrighted slogan of
antifa so here you have an antifa
friendly drag queen dressing up like a
woman and promoting violence talk about
a perfect White House Guest and of
course Cummings is also interested in
children in all the wrong ways Cummings
once tweeted this quote the kids are out
to sing and suck
to perform fellatio oh okay Cummings had
added anyone who thinks drag isn't for
children is wrong
Covington posted this picture with the
child writing he wants to perform with
us next year
so if you think it's unfair to accuse
people of being creepy with kids not
that unfair actually kind of fair
he was coming today Ted Talk in 2019.
I learned how the power of a 20-second
video can change your life how a
20-second clip can change your entire
world view take a look
[Music]
oh that's me and two-year-old Brody at
my Drag Brunch in New Jersey
so a lot of times families come to the
brunch because they're not able to go to
a regular drag show late at night and
it's a time that kids can experience
drag because of baby shark I was able to
come to the pilgrim house and do a
series of kids shows
and I would ask the kids during these
shows I would say what do you want to be
when you grow up and to my surprise a
lot of these kids said they wanted to be
a drag queen
yeah a lot of kids want to be a drag
queen so that's the guy at the White
House today but not really an anomaly it
was just a month ago the administration
invited a guy called Dylan Mulvaney it's
a grown man who identifies as a walking
stereotype of a little girl and he met
the president
so what's going on here well multiple
things of course this is an effort to
degrade the country to make it into a
joke these are people striding through
the hallways
that once were the work area of I don't
know Abraham Lincoln and Teddy Roosevelt
and FDR and whatever you think of their
policies these were serious men who
stayed up late every night
thinking about how to make the country
better another's that guy and a lot of
people like that and Cindy Lauper
celebrating gay marriage which has been
legal since the Obama Administration
what is going on here
well again it's an effort to degrade the
country but as a political matter it's a
distraction
offend you so much or Mesmerize you so
completely that you forget that there
are multiple world's historic crises
unfolding at the same time some of which
the bite Administration caused none of
which it can solve that's the point they
have no idea what to do about the
collapse of the post-war order which is
on display or the continuing slow motion
collapse of the American economy which
you feel because you're poorer than you
were last year and they don't have
anything to say to you
even if they cared they wouldn't have an
answer here's a drag show
welcome to Weimar yeah what happens next
but the point is you lose any
perspective about everything else real
that is happening this is a tactic and
it's not a new tactic actually Joe Biden
once recognized this tactic because if
nothing else he knows politics here's
Biden in 2006 in a clip we were grateful
to get recognizing that complaining
about gay marriage whatever you think of
gay marriage is a pretty handy way for
politicians to distract from their own
failures here's Joe Biden
the world's going to Hades in a
handbasket
we are desperately concerned about the
circumstance relating to avian flu we
don't have enough vaccines we don't have
enough police officers and we're going
to debate the next three weeks I'm told
gay marriage a flag Amendment and God
only knows what else I can't believe the
American people can't see through this
we already have a law the Defense of
Marriage Act we've all voted not or I
voted another said look marriage is
between a man and a woman and states
must respect that
nobody's violated that law there's been
no challenge of that law why do we need
a constitutional amendment marriage is
between a man and a woman
so he gets a pass because that was
pre-dementia he has no memory of saying
any of that now he's just a vessel for
the Ambitions of others but that was an
interesting insight
people talk about stuff like this
particularly when it's not strictly
speaking relevant because they don't
want to talk about other things and that
makes it even more interesting that Joe
Biden's Handler 16 years later are
telling him to talk about gay marriage
and drag shows anything to distract you
and in fact at today's Bill signing just
to completely pull your attention away
from everything else that's going on Joe
Biden came out in favor of both gay
marriage of course because it's been
legal for 10 years and in favor
of the general mutilation of children
here he is
we need a challenge
the hundreds of callus cynical laws
introduced in the states targeting
transgender children
terrifying families and criminalizing
doctors who get children the care they
need we have to protect these children
so they know they are loved and we will
stand up for them and say I can seek for
themselves
it's pretty interesting when you think
about it so this is a bill signing
affirming the legality legalizing once
again gay marriage which most people
support in this country should people
get married if they love each other yeah
they should that's fine not that
controversial point at this stage
but here's Joe Biden using that
opportunity to promote gender affirming
care for kids and of course that means
the sexual mutilation of children
cutting the breasts off 15 year olds
sterilizing them for life with chemicals
that's what Boston Children's Hospital
and many other hospitals have been doing
puberty blockers have fun with
osteoporosis when you're 30. so why
would Joe Biden be promoting that apart
from the fact certain special interest
groups want him to
again this was supposed to be about gay
marriage but here you have Joe Biden
president United States purportedly
pushing child sexual mutilation and then
you have this is even weirder Kamala
Harris out there talking about
contraception really watch
for millions of
lgbtqi plus Americans and interracial
couples
this is a victory
and it is part of a larger fight
the Dobb's decision reminds us
that fundamental rights are
interconnected
including the right to marry who you
love
the right to access contraception
and the right to make decisions about
your own body
now we're just confused the right to buy
contraception now no one on this show is
a legal scholar
but Griswold versus Connecticut came
down in 1967 which affirmed from the
high court the right of Americans to buy
contraception that was
56 years ago
interracial marriage hmm that's been
legal for our lifetimes
no one's trying to make it illegal not
one person is pushing to make that
illegal not one
so here you have Joe Biden and Kamala
Harris of firming your right to buy the
pill and marry someone of A different
race even though neither right is under
attack by anyone why are they doing this
well it's of a piece with their agenda
recently remember this is the same party
that pushed through an anti-lynching
bill this year lynching was that on the
list of major prop are there lynchings
going on wasn't that already illegal no
we just bended for the first time watch
the Senate succeeded in taking long
overdue action by passing the Emmett
Till anti-lynching Act
Hallelujah
Congress has finally declared lynching a
federal crime the people of our nation
deserve the protection of a federal a
federal anti-lynching law
lynching
is not a relic of the past
racial acts of Terror still occur in our
nation
hate will not Prevail in America white
supremacists will not have the last word
we cannot remain silenced silence is
complicity
finally after all these years finally
made lynching the federal crime
after all these years there are a lot of
people were for lynching but we held off
the pro-lynching lobby and we got this
through the Congress we've improved your
life really where are all these
lynchings
were all these racial acts of Terror
committed by white supremacists search
the internet for them you will see some
racial acts of Terror hard to find a lot
committed by white supremacists
any maybe where are the numbers on that
how many racial attacks by white
supremacists have there been in the last
couple years maybe there have been a lot
we're not familiar with that we're not
aware that that actually happened pretty
sure it didn't actually happen we do
know that nooses have appeared in
various places do you remember that
there was one at the construction site
of Barack Obama's new Presidential
Library maybe that's what they're
talking about they offered a six-figure
award to catch the person who tied rope
in a forbidden shape but no culprit was
ever found how weird then there was that
news in the NASCAR garage then there was
a new Surat Jesse smallett's neck is
that the lynching they're banning
the funny thing is
you know that's not real and most people
know it's not real why are they
continuing to say this well because as
actual problems real problems Mount and
they have no answer and no solution and
they're trying to dodge culpability for
creating those problems in the first
place they have to double down on fake
problems we're Banning lynching and no
one laughed
there's not one person that's religion
bill malugin and his team speaking of
real problems just shot this new video
of massive crowds of foreign Nationals
invading our country sorry that's just
true most of them are not from Mexico
they're from very very far away across
the oceans and now they're in a Mexican
border town across from Brownsville
Texas
and they're waiting there for title 42
to end in eight days and when that
happens
when the bite Administration drops that
last piece of legal defense against
Invasion it's going to be an
overwhelming wave of course maybe that's
why they're bringing drag stars and
Cindy Lauper to the White House
because they don't want to talk about I
don't know the threat of nuclear war
from Vladimir Putin
President Vladimir Putin appearing to
dash hopes of a diplomatic solution
warns the war will be long and that the
risk of a nuclear conflict is on the
rise but he quickly dialed back his
language insisting Russia would only use
a nuclear weapon for self-defense never
first it was more of a reminder than an
overt threat
the risk is increasing he said adding we
haven't gone mad we understand what
nuclear weapons are we are not going to
wave it like a razor blade around the
world but of course we must proceed from
the fact that we have it
so we're now at War a hot War not a
proxy war a hot war with Russia American
military personnel lots of U.S
government employees are in Ukraine
fighting that war with American weapons
that you paid for and the guy we're at
war with just threatened to use nuclear
weapons against us now whatever you
think of that war that's not a story
that's not bigger than Banning lynching
or legalizing gay marriage again when it
was already legal or legalizing
contraception which has been legal since
1967 or interracial marriage what
talk about a head fake who's falling for
this oh everyone subscribe to the Fox
News YouTube channel to catch our
nightly opens stories that are changing
the world and changing your life from
Tucker Carlson tonight